pour une quatrième journée le nord de la
syrie est le théâtre de violents
affrontements
l'offensive baptisée rameau d'olivier a
été lancée samedi par la turquie appuyés
par des alliés rebelles syriens contre
l'enclavé affine et 10 à déloger la
milice des unités de protection du
peuple lié payer le dernier front sur le
sol meurtri de la syrie a été ouvert par
la turquie après quoi washington est
annoncé son intention de bâtir une force
de 30000 hommes pour patrouiller la
frontière syrienne dont ferait partie
leye paigc et les combattants douillet
paigc et forme le noyau dur des forces
démocratiques syriennes
la milice arabo kurde soutenu par les
états unis pour combattre le groupe etat
islamique
mais la turquie accusé ip gay d'être la
branche en syrie du parti des
travailleurs du kurdistan
le pkk le groupe mène une guérilla
sanglante en turquie depuis 1984 et il
est classé terroriste par ankara et ses
alliés dans la journée de lundi un
premier soldat turc a été tué et enterré
il y en aura d'autres a prévenu le
président redjep tayyip erdogan en lui
rendant hommage seront des martyrs et
des blessés mais il paye et vont payer
cher pour ça at il dit de ses
adversaires selon le président ordonne
la turquie a demandé et obtenu la
bénédiction de la russie le principal
allié de bachar al assad pour utiliser
l'espace aérien
nous n'allons pas reculer en avons
discuté avec nos amis russes
nous avons un accord at il dit nous en
avons parlé avec d'autres membres de la
coalition et les états unis
les forces démocratiques syriennes se
sont isolés et trahis par leurs alliés
américains et demande à moscou et
washington de clarifier leur position
la turquie n'oserait pas frapper nos
villages et commettre des massacres
contre nos enfants si la russie n'avait
pas failli à ses obligations morales en
donnant le feu vert
parole selon un rapport des nations
unies au moins 5000 personnes ont été
déplacées par les combats des derniers
jours et la population la plus
vulnérable aux bombardements et tirs
d'artillerie seraient coincés s'inquiète
l'onu
l'observatoire syrien des droits de
l'homme affirment que vingt-quatre
civils ont été tués jusqu'ici ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada beyrouth